this is a very interesting new poll I
think about ten people in the last
twelve or so hours sent this to me and
they want me to talk about it so let's
do it
there's a question about the 2020
Democratic primary that many people find
important and some don't and the
question is who of the Democratic
candidates would attract the most Trump
voters people who voted Trump in 2016
who of the Democratic candidates would
have the highest appeal to that group of
people and I've said before I don't
think that the way to win 2020 is by
convincing Trump voters to vote for a
Democrat okay
we're much better off winning on turnout
since half the country doesn't vote
let's just make sure that people who are
already on our side understand the
importance of voting and choose to vote
it is much easier to register 10 people
to vote than to convince at rumpus to
vote for a Democrat in 2020 but that
being said if there is a candidate that
is going to pull way more trumpets over
to our side it would be important to
know that and I would want to know that
and then I can think about well is that
something that I want to consider when
I'm deciding who to support in the
Democratic primary so yesterday people
started sending me a page from a recent
Economist YouGov poll which seems to say
Bernie Sanders followed by Andrew yang
would pull the most 2016 Trump voters to
our side so let's look at the the poll
numbers first and remember I am just the
messenger here I am NOT arguing that
this is the case I am merely showing you
data from a poll which says this is the
case so looking at this you'll notice
that from the people polled who voted
Trump in 2016 this is the furthest right
column on your screen 14 percent say
they'd vote Bernie and 10 percent say
they'd vote for Andrew yang and then in
third place nine percent say they vote
for Pete Buddha judge so this is very
interesting the idea being that Bernie
Sanders is the candidate who would most
bring Trump voters to the Democratic
side and that Andrew yang is the second
highest candidate in terms of who would
bring Trump voters over to the
Democratic side now this is very
interesting but if we want to really
evaluate this we have to look at the
details because there are math questions
about this and there are also political
about this let's start with the math you
will notice at the bottom right of the
image that it says unweighted n41
this means that the sample size of Trump
voters for this question unweighted was
41 people out of the 41 Trump voters
included in this sample 14% said they'd
vote Bernie and 10% for yang that's six
people saying that they voted for Trump
in 2016 but would vote Bernie in in 2020
and four for yang these are not exactly
the large numbers around which I would
necessarily be taking away too much but
that doesn't mean that the data is not
still interesting now more importantly
there's a political question here just
because Trump aspra fer Bernie and yang
/ whoever else that doesn't mean they
would actually vote for them over Trump
the question was if the Democratic
presidential primary in your state were
held today who would you vote for okay
just because at rumpus voting in the DEM
primary would choose Bernie or yang
doesn't mean they would choose Bernie or
yang over Trump in the general election
that's a really important thing to
understand the other element of this is
that you might say wait a second why
would trumpets
be voting why would trump who voted for
Trump in 2016 even be voting in the 2020
Democratic primary
that's another relevant question because
based on how it is in the poll the 41
people answering that question are 2016
Trump voters who say they will be voting
in the 2020 Democratic primary when the
sample is 41 and we don't know if there
are people who are Republicans in a
state with an open primary who are going
to vote in the Democratic primary we
don't know if some of them are lying
about having voted for Donald Trump we
don't know if some of them are lying
about planning to vote in the 2020
primary the point is when you've got
just 41 people if just three people here
lied then the numbers all of a sudden
become much less significant now all of
that being said to go back to the
initial question with all of the things
that we can consider in thinking about
which 2020 a Democratic candidate we
should be supporting
I actually do not believe that picking a
candidate because a slightly higher
portion of Trumpets would consider
voting for them is a good strategy
because we are going to have to win
despite the trumpets not by convincing
them and big picture particularly since
the preference for one Democrat over
another does not tell us that they would
even vote for that person over Trump in
the general election I don't know that
the right approach is to be looking at
polls and saying well 14 percent would
vote Bernie 10 percent would vote yang
I'm gonna make a decision on that basis
I think we should be supporting the
progressive candidate I'm a progressive
so I want to look for a progressive
candidate whose policy ideas most match
ours period and then once we have a
Democratic nominee selected we should be
working on get out the vote half the
country doesn't vote let's find people
who are already sympathetic to our
political beliefs but who may not be
planning to vote and get them to
register and vote convincing trumpets
either by calculating the Democratic
nominee that would most appeal to them
or just like debating trumpets and
trying to beat them over the head with
logic into voting for a Democrat that is
not the strategy that will remove Trump
in 2020 if you disagree with me I'm open
to having my mind changed follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman and tell me
exactly where and why you disagree with
me you can also follow the David Pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access
the entire library of fun easy-to-use
online courses for free for two months
by using the link underneath this video
two months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video